bootleg cat podcast shout out to my guy
Armin got his new mixtape coming out
with just incredible on the 16th go run
it up yeah uh
uh new singles out all the time you got
a yellow Habibi that came out there she
got a lot of [ __ ] going on man yes sir
you got [ __ ] weed strain store
the clothing line yeah man we working go
follow uh or me I always wondered I mean
uh why is your name Armin if you're such
a nice guy
it's actually my real name spelled
differently I was just I was I was
hoping you were gonna say it because I'm
Armenian and I would have been like I
had no idea that's what everyone thinks
too everyone thinks I call myself Army
short for Armenian it's a whole thing
bro it all works out though it all works
out it all works out in the Armenian
language Armenian isn't even Army you
know I mean it's like it's a whole
different thing so it's listen listen to
this rapid language as we mean on the
mic that's what it comes down to let's
go let's go
come on come on we rolling yeah yeah yo
yo my name is Armin yes sir yeah
uh I had to face off with fear and it
was first to look away walk and make the
streets crack how I mean I'm cooking yay
now you hear the line roll all you see
is a giant all got a lot of [ __ ] like
old Kanye with a wire jaw I'm hearing
Christ and the devil both in my inner
voice going back and forth like it's m
and Royce Bad Meets Evil the original
Renegade finally making peace with the
mirror but then slowly watched the
reflection change nothing like these
other kids is what my mom was thinking
and nine years old wanna figure it out
I'm just why you're different it took
some years some darkness and heavy
grinding me befriending somebody blind
for me to see my entire Vision mama said
ain't no shortcuts to God's Mission yeah
ain't no microwaves in God's kitchen
yeah while I'm cooking I hear a lot of
hissing [ __ ] think they hard to
read like a doctor prescription and ever
since they heard a mean a pharmacist
rappers asking me for lean Zanny bars
and [ __ ] fake vaccination because dog
the y'all get pissed cause all they
really get from me is boys as hard as
this hardest your daughter's clits good
thing the minutes are limited how they
call it quits 20 homies in the studio
get no credits as writers but on some
John starting this [ __ ] dog they all
assist I crumble them like a piece of
paper and then ball my fists and yell
out Kobe when I throw them all in the
garbage pits check out my form and
wrists
swish
oh I Dash the greatest you never heard
the greatest you about to hear rappers
gonna have to respect them even if it's
out of fear I was taught to show respect
to the legends that God is here [ __ ]
them came full circle when I got a verse
from Nasir yeah next I might go [ __ ]
with funk Flex I just shot your baby
mom's a drunk text cash these rappers
slipping like a young X Ashton Kutcher
with a rat game Who getting punked next
sharpening my sword like young buck at
the vibe Awards you look all kinds of
laws these records be movies and these
verses be monologues this ain't for you
regular people this for the kind of
sores you think the Lamborghini suffer
from depression how we got the suicidal
doors no never mind the course the
passion in your heart they match with
what's inside the voice that's why your
[ __ ] give me hit while I'm inside of
yours rent free for the whole month
you're getting piped like I got my weed
but got no blunts or dash mean fill EMC
do my own stunts of friction you don't
want I represent the Lord's tries my
Bloodlines are for me any origin raising
Amsterdam born where the angels are lost
again I lost my father when I was little
and ever since I've been using the mic
the blurry color lines of my life that
racism [ __ ] is detrimental I'm hip hop
my heart beats a Primo instrumental or
maybe Alchemists no need to get all
technical you get the message bro
nothing but pure intentions flow inside
of my heart and my ventricles I let them
know from the debts of my soul till the
day I returned to my Essence Imma Be
repping no test me bro I am the greatest
great is an understatement a hate of a
hundred haters and make me this
underrated underestimated on the dog
under the payment my brother we
unrelated underground where I'm
stationed underappreciated but under the
undenound proof lies the underlying
truth it's undebated I'm the one they
know this now I used to be the black
sheep of my family somehow became The
Golden Child
yeah I used to be the black sheep of my
family somehow come on man
you know what I mean I've only done this
one at a time
thank you nobody can use that mic
anymore to rap
armeen
hey what up I know you just watched a
crazy freestyle and guess what we got
another one coming out next week and
another one coming out the week after
and it's all presented by our family at
LRG that's right LRG uh first of all
shout out to them because they just
dropped this fire collab with Ewing
Athletics they got the sneakers they got
the sweatsuit the T-shirt all that plus
I want to give a big shout out to them
because it is Christmas time and my
promo code at lrg's website is a serious
one you saved 30 off 30 off if you go to
L Dash R
g.com and use the promo code bootleg
you'll save 30 off whatever the [ __ ] you
want on lrg's website so it's Christmas
time maybe you need some new gear maybe
you need a new jacket maybe you need a
new [ __ ] sweatsuit whatever it is
l-r-g.com we appreciate them for holding
us down use that promo code bootleg save
30 off and we'll see you next week with
another freestyle presented by LRG